he's Grant Hill of Turner Sports and CBS
how are you grant I'm good I'm good how
are you I'm doing great
what was that like watching UMBC take
out Virginia Grant what was that like
walk me through it please yeah you know
it was it was I was in total disbelief
and you know you just felt like you know
early in the game you felt like at some
point Michigan's gonna make a ruttin and
I receive that Michigan I heard you
submission Michigan Virginia Virginia
was gonna make a run and obviously the
way they played they don't you know play
with a lot of pace but you just felt
like at some point okay things would
turn and particularly coming out of
halftime where adjustments are made and
and Michigan are screaming Virginia had
a couple guys in foul trouble I think
Wilkins was in foul trouble and it was
almost as if at halftime UMBC like felt
wow we're just as good as his team we
can beat this team so they were the team
that came out in that second half score
was tied 21 to 21 and it was just an
unbelievable performance second half
defensively and of course on the
offensive end against the best defense a
team that just smothered other teams
defensively teams could not score they
couldn't get into the paint dribble
penetration was non-existent against
them and you NBC could do whatever they
wanted and and so it was just even as
the second half started and it was like
they just got more and more confident as
the game wore on and so I probably did a
horrible job on the call because I was
just I was shocked you guys were great
you got no but but you were giving voice
to what we were all thinking watching it
grant I mean at one point I think Nance
even said the rhetorical question of
what is happening to Virginia I think
that came out of his mouth because and
good that was great because that's what
was coming out of my mouth and I'm sure
down in in in Virginia you know there
might have been an expletive or two
coming out as well you know well if
you're right it was so out of character
I mean but
a team that throughout the regular
season dominating in the ACC which you
know you could argue and say was the top
conference or one of the top conferences
this year but just never being rattled
never you know never being worried upset
you know playing the way they played and
just having their composure and you saw
that they were were rattled they
couldn't figure it this team out you
know they couldn't stop them that was
the first thing and offensively once
they got down Virginia not very good at
playing catch-up although the twice I
think twice they were down a double
digits in the regular season and they
came back and won those games but it was
just it was just watching this team sort
of implode in part but also watching
this the Cinderella story this this UMBC
team just have an unbelievable game was
shocking it is the thing I was worried
here you are we're broadcasting that day
and the first date of tournament is
always the hardest day because you have
four games and it's just it's like
climbing a mountain and the Virginia
UMBC game was gonna be the last was the
last game of the day and you're just
thinking oh it's gonna be a slow game
slow pace I even thought from watching I
watched four games of UMBC prior to that
game I watched their conference
tournament games I watched the
regular-season game they had against
Vermont in their conference and I'm
thinking they may not score against
Virginia like that was sort of you know
full disclosure that was what I was
thinking as I'm preparing and I'm just
like oh this is going to be so hard to
maintain a level of energy and it turned
out to be the best game and this team
you know not only did they score I mean
they they just they had the best
offensive performance against the number
one defense in all college basketball
truly amazing yeah and that's the
personification of March Madness it's
something again that we won't forget
Grant Hill here on the Rich Eisen show
alright now let's get to the midwest
region in omaha where you Nance Raftery
and the crew are heading Duke play in
the 2-3 zone grant what do you think
about that taking on Syracuse with their
own defense
yeah I mean Syracuse is funny they this
is a team that you know once again you
have to credit baeyer and the job he
does and just how he seems to get his
team ready at the right time of the
season they had a run a few years ago
that no one expected they got to the
Final Four and this team is more than
capable I think the thing that helps
Duke in this case is that they've seen
the zone they've seen Jim Boeheim zone
and how they play and they've seen this
team in the regular season and so that
helps that helps tremendously I think
you know sometimes a team like Syracuse
because they're so long and athletic and
so connected in that zone a lot of teams
out of conference aren't accustomed to
playing against that zone obviously Bay
Hyman Coach K are great friends they
coached together for I think 10 12 years
and USA basketball so they're both you
know very familiar which also works in
Syracuse is favored as well so because
they're an 11th seed he should not look
past them they are more than capable of
being Duke they're not going to be
intimidated by Duke they beat a very
good Michigan State team at home
virtually in Detroit and and so you know
it's going to be tough and I think
Duke's gonna want to try to get out a
little bit in transition try to get some
easy baskets before Syracuse is zone
sets up and you know Syracuse right now
it's just there's a good rhythm there's
a good rhythm to their game they're
comfortable they're confident they're
doing a great job on the offensive end
they you know Michigan State a great
defensive team Tom Izzo so yeah I mean
this is not a normal to feed verson 11
seed it could go either way and then you
know if I had told you grant or most
people before the tournament that we
would see the first tournament since
2004 in which 2-1 seeds would not make
the sweet 16 and you had to choose which
of the two 1 seeds wouldn't make it I
would prefer to say Kansas would be in a
lot of those answers based on some of
the disappointments we've seen from the
Jayhawks in recent years yet there they
are taking on a Clemson team that
eviscerated
Aubert I mean just took them apart how
do you see that one playing out in Omaha
that's gonna be an interesting game you
know Kansas not your typical season in
the big 12 I think was was really tough
to season very talented I think they had
some moments there played good ball at
the end and then Bill Self I mean he you
know he's been here he's won before he's
got some you know Devonte Graham is a
special player who as a senior provides
you know not just great play but great
leadership but wow this Clemson team I
mean they they are something else they
defend they can really score the
basketball I have three guys on the
perimeter who are all shot-makers
playmakers all capable of scoring from
three getting to the basket
they have great spacing on offense and
you know they went against New Mexico
State in the first round in New Mexico
State I think was the fourth or fifth
best defense and and they just you know
they had their way they did whatever
they want and of course the Auburn game
Auburn another really good defensive
team and also a good offensive team
actually team that can really score you
know they went through a 1012 minute
period there too in the first half where
they didn't score field goal so you know
Clemson sort of not a team that we're
accustomed to seeing played this second
week but they're more than capable and
more than you know capable of going out
there and and beating Kansas and so you
know look when we did the the selection
show we did a little hit our broadcast
crew after the AAC tournament yeah and
you know one of the things that stood
out before the game started was that
that Midwest Conference looks tough when
you looked at the top four seeds you
looked at Kansas you looked at Michigan
State you looked at Duke and I can't
remember in ours it was in Auburn yes I
mean you were just thinking wow this
this is pretty special and even though
those teams got a upset the teams that
are there are very very good so I'm
excited to be there
I've never been to Omaha I hear it's a
great basketball town - great great
and I think we'll have some great games
there this this upcoming weekend and
then before you before I let you go
grant
you know I've got so many people saying
hey what a golden opportunity this is
for Michigan the one and two seeds are
out and then you know they're gonna take
on it maybe a fifth seeded Kentucky
which would be you know obviously a lot
going on there but there's a nine and
eleven and a seven in the south of
course there's a seven seed in Texas A&M
that looked terrific destroying North
Carolina in front of your eyes how do
you see that matchup between Michigan
and Texas A&M Wow this Texas A&M team is
really good they honest all the Michigan
team we did the big Big Ten Conference
tournament the semis in the finals and
obviously very familiar with Coach
beeline and how they play and how you
know how what kind of success they have
and they obviously you know they got
lucky there I'll say that they're
against Houston but I do think to win a
championship at some point you have to
be lucky and and so they got past
Houston but Texas A&M they have first of
all they start three guys that are six
Niner tall and they have great size
inside Robert Williams is just I mean he
every rebound every block shot every
time he jumps it's just like it's a
sight to see
and of course Davis is a big body
post-up well very skilled very good at
getting to the free-throw line
they have the kid who's six nine small
forward kind of does everything
beautiful shooting stroke they're big
they're quick they defend they they're
they're a potential final 14 you know
their team that could even win it I mean
III just I was so impressed with their
collective effort their defense their
offense that the point guard Starks he's
the key he's a he's a guy who is a shoot
first loves more I heard you say you
said he loves short clocks
yes exactly does he does and he and he
you know we met with the kid we visited
with him in between the first round the
second round he talked about how you
know learning to become more of a
decision maker and his playmaker and
facilitator instead of a shooter
instincts he wants to score and so we
know that to win a championship to beat
a Michigan team and so good on both ends
of the floor
the point guard play is essential but
Michigan I mean they're good they
they're defending this year I mean
that's the thing they're really getting
after you on the defensive end
they got good app I think they're more
athletic than they have been in recent
years vogner's sort of can do it all
spaces the floor the beeline offense so
that is going to be a really really good
game and that's not gonna be an easy
opponent for the Wolverine before I let
you go grant
you know I'm going to the game it's here
in Los Angeles and bring in my family
and I'm really nervous about jinxing him
just physically being there because I'm
like that superstitious guy grant so I
ask you who's the most superstitious
person you've ever been around played
with you include yourself coach who's
the one that it's always been the most
well the most superstitious person I've
ever been around my dad and you know I
mean I didn't obviously play with him or
anything but but you know during during
the tournament run and even my mom the
entire four years at Duke my mom would
say that you know he would wear the same
clothes he would you know go to the same
restaurant if we were on the road and we
won that first game on a Friday
you know we'd go to go to the same
restaurant and and everyone had to sit
in the same seats and everyone had to
order the same meal that they had the
day before or the day of that the
previous game and she said my mom she he
would wear you know he wear this sort of
white button-down shirt and he'd only
bring one and so he'd wear it you know
the first game and then he wear it again
the next day and he didn't get it clean
and so but he is by far the most
superstitious person that I know and you
know hey whatever he was doing it worked
because we have some some pretty good
success Beck did when I was in school
did he get it from his cowboy days is
that where you got a thought yeah I
don't know III just I think he's just
like that I mean he's he is very he
doesn't believe you can't split the pole
so if you're walking down the street and
you walk but you don't know you walk
back around like you can't split the
pole you see a black cat like
all you know very superstitious and
probably mad and I told the whole world
but no but but before I let your last
thing again he did allow Roger Staubach
to name you though when it all came down
to it is that a true story you know what
it was it's a true story and it's one of
those stories that I was told when I was
little and I grew up in DC big Cowboys
fan so that was what I would always brag
about but I never really had
confirmation on that story and I you
know Roger Staubach and his family are a
good family friends so you know I got a
little older I asked and he said it was
a true story you know my dad was
expecting a girl and that was at a time
when you you know you couldn't find out
the sex of the baby and he had all these
girls names picked out and you know and
so obviously I came out I wasn't a boy
but you know so you know I was baby boy
he'll for like two or three days in the
hospital and like a good quarterback he
came in took control of the huddle and
and came up with that name so it's
pretty pretty cool and you know it's
good that uh you know as a cowboy fan to
have the ultimate cowboy responsible for
your name is great story grant love
listening to you like I said really
enjoying the call with you and Raftery
and Nance and the whole CBS crew it's
it's great thanks for thanks for they
call in here grant all right I
appreciate you thanks Richard you got it
it's Grant Hill at Turner Sports the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience